let's talk about what
actually happened and let me give you a
play-by-play as
everything this past year it all starts
with the pandemic
the coronavirus hits the stock market
plummets it goes from almost thirty
thousand down to eighteen thousand
and all as they say you know buy low
sell high and a lot of
new investors enter the marketplace so
that tease this
entire situation up so enter this wall
street bet form a lot of new investors
day traders are basically saying let's
take advantage
of the lowest market the stock market's
been in almost a decade
let's start investing they're starting
to invest and they're starting to invest
in and they're talking on this form
so that sets the stage for exactly what
happens then meanwhile you got these
hedge funds
doing what they do looking to take
advantage and manipulate the market and
certain basically
short certain stocks so that's how they
get started and if you're not familiar
with short selling
let me just give you a quick little tip
with that it's basically betting
against the stock you don't like it you
don't own it you don't want it
you're taking out debt essentially to
short
the stock and that's how you can lose
very
badly when the stock goes up more on
that in a second
so these big hedge funds are basically
shorting these stocks and these
redditors
start to take notice they say look we
don't like these
wall streeters hedge funds taking
advantage of us little guys
let's try to fight back so they were
motivated and galvanized
to basically take on the hedge funds so
why uh you know why are they looking to
take on the hedge funds obviously
they're sick of the
corporate greed the manipulation of the
market and they're basically going to
give them a little taste
of their own medicine so basically
here's what's happening here's what's
happening
the the hedge funds are shorting the
market these guys are trying to
fight back and they get galvanized by
none other
than elon musk elon musk is no fan of
short sellers
because basically there were millions of
short sellers who were trying to short
tesla we all know what happened
with tesla since the pandemic they've
skyrocketed
to the moon a little shout out to the
spacex right there so basically
elon musk is basically saying listen i
don't like any part of this he quote
unquote says this
you can't sell houses you don't own you
can't sell cars you don't own
but you can sell stock you don't own
this is bs
shorting is a scam so that's elon musk's
thoughts on this
obviously the redditors pay attention to
his every word they're basically saying
yeah we agree with this
let's fight even harder against these
hedge fund short sellers
and then elon musk sees what's going on
and he tweets one word he goes
game stocks game stocks you've seen the
meme with the stunks
out there so he tweets that next thing
you know game stocks
stock price goes from two dollars and
fifty cents to five dollars
to fifty dollars to as high as five
hundred
dollars two dollars to five hundred
dollars this is crazy
obviously the stock is now cratering
these days but that's what happened in
this past week
so citron research one of those hedge
funds that i talked about that was
famous
for short selling they kind of egged on
some of these reddit investors here's
what they said
game stock buyers are the suckers at
this poker game so they sort of poked
the bear of these reddit investors which
only encouraged the wall street bench
community to buy
even more game stock stock so basically
what ends up happening is these short
sellers do you know how much they lost
do you know how much they lost
not a billion not 5 billion not 10
billion
over 20 billion dollars
on game stop alone that's a lot of bread
right there it's a lot of games so
basically
the hedge funds are losing money these
redditer guys are making money one guy
turned
47 000 into 47 million dollars this is
unheard of this is crazy
so shout out to that guy tip of the cap
i hope you sold
at the top and actually made some money
turned in 47 000
to 47 million this is unheard of this is
crazy citron research is obviously not
happy about losing billions and billions
of billions of dollars
they basically say that the reddit users
are a quote unquote
angry mob and they vow to quit
publicly commenting about gamestop yeah
no [ __ ] you're going to publicly stop
commenting you just lost a few billion
you might want to
zip it up for a little bit citron so
basically that's what happens and then
you got
robin hood robin hood's stuck in the
middle we all heard that song
stuck in the middle with you you got
clowns in the left of me you got jokers
to the right
here they are stuck in the middle and
why is robin hood stuck in the middle
why because they get their funding from
these big
wall street firms so they don't like
that they're getting shorted but all
their clients
are these individual investors so
they're stuck in the middle and they got
to pick a path
so basically what happens is they stop
trading they halt trading they basically
say
you can no longer buy the gamestop stock
you can only sell
now i'm not sure how well-versed you are
in the stock market but if you can't buy
and you can only sell the stock price
will only go down that's just basically
how that works so robin hood is starting
to get a lot of hate you got dave
portnoy basically saying
what the hell is going on here these
guys should go to jail you got fed
regulators sec
all commenting on what's going on the
politicians are weighing in aoc is
saying
well you know how come these hedge fund
guys can treat the economy and the
market like
uh like a monopoly game but all of a
sudden when the reddit guys want to do
it
you want to try and complain and take
your ball home so that's what's going on
there's a lot of drama out there
basically robin hood gets a lot of heat
and
in essence elon musk who is sort of
stirring up the controversy actually
does a public phone call with vlad
tenniv the ceo of
robin hood and says dude what's going on
here please explain this
to me so vlad obviously he's been on the
news he's been on cnbc he's been
everywhere
trying to explain his position on this
he's caught between a rock and a hard
place
because again he answers to wall street
but he also has to answer
to who his clients are on robin hood
these individual investors